freuen wir uns immer endlich wieder
pfeffer im lahmen wahlkampf ist doch
schön und die frage lautet wie reagiert
die cdu auf den neuen herausforderer
geschalten mal live ins konrad adenauer
haus zu albrecht humboldt arbeitete
halbtags in der cdu wahlkampfzentrale
albrecht was bedeutet denn die
personalie schulz jetzt für euch in der
union
wir nehmen das als herausforderung
klar sie hatten unsere kampagne
natürlich schon komplett auf gabriel
eingestellt blöd können wir jetzt alles
wegschmeißen
es ist schon ein bisschen unglücklich da
muss man die nerven global
denn eigentlich ist das was die spd da
macht eine riesensauerei
das war doch ganz klar abgesprochen dass
der unsympathische dicke kohle liga
antritt dieser schulz der der der hat ja
schon fast menschliche züge also auch
alles ganz klar geregelt die spd tritt
grundsätzlich mit looser typen
angezogene zumstein hieß steinmeier wir
sprechen den raufasertapete oder
steinbrück der hat für 500 euro in den
bau macht eröffnet das sind rot den
kanzlerkandidaten verstehe sie sind
quasi beleidigt dass die spd sich noch
nicht ganz aufgegeben hat ja ja
natürlich
dann steht die spd dieser lege fall
unter den parteien auf einmal für
frischen wind bei uns in der cdu gibt es
nur frischen wind wenn peter altmaier
im letzten wahlkampf hat es noch
ausgereicht dass wir das hier plakatiert
haben laut feierabend dankeschön
ich habe jetzt keinen bock mehr
na ja noch führt die cdu ihr haus hoch
in den umfragen
wie soll ich die merkel denn bitte noch
irgendwie anders oder oder neu verkaufen
nach 500 jahren im kanzleramt
wir haben hier so viel an ihren fotos
rum manipuliert bei photoshop sind schon
die farben alle was willst du denn da
noch machen
ich habe ihr sogar schon eine freche
frauke petry verpackt plus den martin
schulz bat die wähler erkennen sie immer
noch was sie hat schon wieder bilder mit
flüchtlingen gemacht
albrecht und meine damen und herren wir
werden sie nie vergessen
o